One of my favorite comics,
masterpiece mouse,
comes in the very first chapter here.
The comic,
if you don't know,
is about spiegelman's father's
experience in the Holocaust.
More specifically,
it's about spiegelman's own efforts to
come to grips with that experience while
navigating a really strained
relationship with his dad.
Mouse is obsessed with this
correspondence between the past and the
present and it's a theme that Spiegelman
is determined to workout visually in his
comic.
How does he do that?
Well,
let's take a look at the page that I
mentioned earlier.
Panel by panel in the first
spiegelman's.
Father Vladik takes his grown son
already backup to his old bedroom after
dinner so that he can do some exercise
already.
The past is signaled here with the empty
bedroom.
Have a child that's moved out in the
second panel.
We get a closer look at that room and
what Vlad ics done with it.
More remnants of the past,
like the pennant banner from
Spiegelman's College Harper,
where he studied art and philosophy.
We get our first glimpse of the
exercycle that Vladik uses to work out,
and this is where art broaches,
the subject of the book that we're
reading now,
notice that the body's of both father
and son are leaning at the same angle,
spiegelman's asking his dad to open up
so he parallels his body language.
He's also equating these two men
visually and the book will continue to
compare and contrast them until the end.
In the third panel,
the heads are parallel this time arts
looking at a picture,
but we won't learn what it is until a
few panels down and the fourth panel,
nothing changes,
but art's head which swivels around to
his father as he makes his request
explicit,
and then we come to the fifth panel
which stretches the entire width of the
page.
It has a lot going on right away.
You can see three key signifiers of the
past,
the picture,
the identification,
Tattoo Vladik received outfits and the
speech bubble where Vladik says it would
take many books my life and no one wants
anyway to hear such stories as critic
Hillary Chute notes.
It's as if the past articulated,
inscribed in documented were flanking
both men closing in on them,
and of course within this rd is enclosed
by his father.
In the six panel,
we learned that the photograph is of
already mother on Joe,
which helps us understand the panels
that came before.
In the seventh panel,
we see Vladik shoe peddling with effort
on the bike,
but going nowhere.
Then in the eighth and final circular
panel,
we get our first window into the past,
into the story within a story that will
consume the book.
The different shape signals,
a new narrative thread.
While the image of latic echoes the
photograph that's been a dominant
feature of the rest of the page
and a comic.
You have various panels.
Those panels are each units of time.
You see them simultaneously,
so you have various moments in time
simultaneously made present.
That's art spiegelman explaining why
it's a bit unfair to do what I just did
and considered the value of a panel on
its own.
For spiegelman,
the basic unit of comics is the page,
its basic function,
that interplay of moments that happens
when you take in several panels all at
once in a way that's unique to comics.
Time is made spatial spread out across a
surface so that you can see not only how
the past affects the future,
but vice versa.
What you learn here,
that this picture is of art's Mom,
white ex wife who committed suicide,
transforms the meaning of this look here
and all it takes is a glance,
the slightest movement in the eyes to
access that connection.
You don't need to rewind or read back or
start over again on the page.
Those two moments exist simultaneously.
In this sense,
graphic design becomes a vital part of
comic making.
As the Great Cartoonist Seth Aka Gregory
Golan once said,
the words and pictures that make up the
comics language are often described as
pros and illustration combined a bad
metaphor.
Poetry and graphic design seems more
apt.
Poetry for the rhythm and condensing
graphic design because cartooning is
more about moving shapes around
designing than it is about drawing.
This page of mouse is the perfect
illustration of that sentiment and take
a closer look.
What do you see in this design?
What about now in Spiegelman's book and
life?
His father is a towering figure,
is experience surviving.
The most horrifying event in history
becomes the central fact and not just
his life but in his sons and that's how
the trauma of the Holocaust invaded the
world and how the past invades the
present in mouse Vladik literally
invades the page and pumping away on his
exercycle as shoot points out already.
His father is literally unable to move
forward,
which is why it makes sense that the
past begins in the wheel.
If that blank art spiegelman set out to
create a comic that would be readable,
that's why he spent 13 years writing,
drawing and designing mouse.
Every page is a new pattern to pick
apart.
A new configuration of moments passed
and president words and images.
Father and son.
This attention to design is why mouse is
often regarded as the best graphic novel
ever written.
It's not that the subject matter is
inherently dramatic and effecting which
it is.
It's that spiegelman wanted to tell a
story in a way that was unique to the
comics medium though to extract the
truth of the Holocaust and I'll just
family that only comics could tell.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
If you want to be notified the next time
under greater video comes out,
be sure to subscribe to the channel by
clicking the link below almost at 2
million subscribers,
which is crazy.
You can help me get there by
subscribing.
Thank you so much.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a super easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates.
It just makes the process so simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service
upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy to.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code nerd
writer,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.
Okay,
real quick.
Here's another page I really love for
the way that it plays with how a comics
page is normally read.
It's the point in the story when black
is first entering Auschwitz.
Now everyone who reads comics knows that
you're meant to go left to right,
then down,
then left,
right again,
but here spiegelman cleverly uses
overlapping speech bubbles to pull you
down the left side,
and at that point you have to read down
again and that becomes a descent into
the beast.
Small,
horrifying,
but beautiful.
Anyway,
see you guys.